A former NFL player becomes the quintessential
tall tough guy.
A star trades his badge for border terriers.
And one cadet transitions into a lifelong
Santa Claus.
The stars of "Police Academy" moved on to
other things, but which of them were bigger
or better?
Keep watching to find out.
Steve Guttenberg was already gaining plenty
of traction in his screen acting career, thanks
to films like "Diner" and TV series like "Billy"
by the time the role of Carey Mahoney in "Police
Academy" came to him.
Guttenberg's lovable scoundrel performance
in the film helped make it a hit — and helped
launch him into some of the biggest films
of the 1980s.
Throughout the rest of the decade, he starred
in three "Police Academy" sequels as well
as "Short Circuit," "Cocoon," and "3 Men and
a Baby."
He continued working regularly in the 1990s
in comedy and family films like "The Big Green,"
"Home for the Holidays," and "It Takes Two,"
and in the 2000s he won a role in cult favorite
TV series "Veronica Mars."
Today he continues acting regularly, and in
2017 he started appearing alongside Dwayne
Johnson in the HBO series "Ballers."
In 2002, he moved behind the camera, making
his directorial debut with an adaptation of
James Kirkwood Jr.'s play "P.S.
Your Cat Is Dead."
By the time "Police Academy" arrived in theaters,
Kim Cattrall had already co-starred in one
classic of the 1980s, playing a somewhat infamous
role in the 1981 comedy "Porky's."
As cadet Karen Thompson, she got to become
a little more of a fully-fledged character,
which led to more high-profile films throughout
the rest of the decade — though she didn't
return for any of the "Police Academy" sequels.
"Why?"
"Because it's exciting - it's different!
It'll give me a chance to meet interesting
and unusual people."
Cattrall followed up "Police Academy" with
roles in "Big Trouble in Little China," "Mannequin,"
"Star Trek 6: The Undiscovered Country," and
more, but the role of her life was yet to
come.
In 1998 she was cast as Samantha Jones in
the HBO comedy "Sex and the City," and her
performance as the sex-positive, outrageous
member of the show's key foursome made her
a fan favorite.
She remained with the show throughout its
six-season run on HBO, and later returned
as Samantha for two feature films.
Since "Sex and the City" ended, she has continued
working regularly, including roles in the
TV series "Producing Parker," "Sensitive Skin,"
"Modus," and "Tell Me a Story."
George Gaynes' screen acting credits already
stretched back nearly 30 years by the time
he was cast as Commandant Lassard in "Police
Academy," and his work included roles in "Columbo,"
"Washington: Behind Closed Doors," and "Tootsie."
Playing Lassard brought Gaynes a new level
of visibility for 1980s moviegoers, and it
was the first step toward a new level of stardom.
That new stardom also included a leading role
in the sitcom "Punky Brewster," in which he
played Henry Warnimont and voiced the character
again in an animated spinoff series.
Between "Police Academy" and "Punky Brewster,"
Gaynes became an icon of 1980s pop culture.
He continued working regularly throughout
the 1990s with roles in "The Days and Nights
of Molly Dodd," "Hearts of Fire," and continued
to play Lassard in all six "Police Academy"
sequels as well as a brief appearance in the
TV series.
By the end of the 1990s, Gaynes had largely
retired from screen acting, and his last appearance
was a brief role in the 2003 comedy "Just
Married."
He died on February 15, 2016 at the age of
98.
Michael Winslow started appearing in films
in 1980, and co-starred in two Cheech & Chong
films before "Police Academy" rolled around
in 1984.
As cadet Larvelle Jones, Winslow's incredible
talent for generating seemingly any sound
effect with only his mouth made him one of
the standout stars, and cemented his place
in the pop culture of the 1980s.
"(noises) "Game over".
Winslow continued to play Jones in every subsequent
sequel.
He also returned to play Larvelle Jones as
a police sergeant in the "Police Academy"
TV series in 1997.
Outside the "Police Academy" franchise, Winslow
has kept busy ever since, with roles in "The
Love Boat," "Spaceballs," "Harry and the Hendersons,"
and more.
Unsurprisingly, he's also a gifted voice actor
who has loaned his talents to the "New Kids
on the Block" animated series, "Grand Theft
Auto: San Andreas," "Robot Chicken" and more.
He's also a stand-up comedy performer and
released a concert film in 1999.
In addition to acting, Winslow is also a musician
who has released his own music and collaborated
with acts including Run the Jewels and Victor
Wooten.
Before "Police Academy," Leslie Easterbrook
was best known for playing Rhonda Lee, the
neighbor of the title characters of the hit
sitcom "Laverne & Shirley," for its final
three seasons between 1980 and 1983.
As Sgt.
Callahan in "Police Academy," she played the
tough-as-nails woman in a man's job who also
had a secret side, and while she didn't return
for "Police Academy 2," she did reprise her
role for the remaining five sequels and the
TV series.
After "Police Academy," Easterbrook continued
working regularly, racking up dozens of television
appearances in the 1980s and 1990s, including
guest spots on "Murder, She Wrote," "Hanging
with Mr. Cooper," "Hunter," "Matlock," and
"Baywatch."
In 2005 she took over the role of Mother Firefly
in Rob Zombie's "The Devil's Rejects," and
since then has become something of a scream
queen, appearing in horror films including
Zombie's own "Halloween" remake, "The Afflicted,"and
"Sorority Party Massacre."
G.W. Bailey was already an established character
actor with guest starring roles on "St. Elsewhere,"
"M*A*S*H," "Goodnight, Beantown," and others
when he was cast as the brutal Lt. Harris
in "Police Academy."
"You people are going to hate my guts for
the rest of your lives!
I am going to make you sorry that you ever
came here."
He continued to play Lt. Harris throughout
the "Police Academy" franchise, and has worked
regularly ever since.
Among Bailey's numerous screen credits are
the films "Short Circuit," "Mannequin," and
a voice role in the animated "Home on the
Range."
He has appeared even more frequently on television,
including the miniseries "War and Remembrance"
and the series "The Jeff Foxworthy Show,"
"Murder, She Wrote," "American Dreams," and
"The Closer."
In "The Closer," he played LAPD Detective
Lt. Louie Provenza for 109 episodes, then
crossed over into the TNT drama series "Major
Crimes," where he played the character until
the series ended in 2018.
David Graf spent several years working primarily
as a guest actor on episodes of various TV
series before he was cast in the career-defining
role of Tackleberry in "Police Academy."
Tackleberry, a gung-ho security guard who
couldn't wait to join the police force and
seemed to always be armed and ready to shoot
something, was a key archetype in the original
film, and became one of the franchise's most
recognizable characters.
"Son, where did you get this gun?"
"My mom gave it to me."
Graf returned to reprise the role for all
six sequels, and co-starred in the "Police
Academy" television series in the late 1990s.
Graf continued working regularly in film and
television throughout the 1980s and 1990s.
In 1986 he co-starred in the short-lived sitcom
"He's The Mayor," and in the 1990s and early
2000s he appeared frequently in TV series
including "Seinfeld," "Home Improvement,"
"Step by Step," and "Star Trek: Deep Space
Nine."
He was also an accomplished voice actor, appearing
in series and video games including "Aaahh!
Real Monsters!," and "The Wild Thornberrys."
He died suddenly from a heart attack on April
7, 2001, at the age of 50.
An imposing figure but a lovable guy, Moses
Hightower is probably the most memorable and
beloved character from the entire "Police
Academy" franchise.
It's the signature role of Charles "Bubba"
Smith, an NFL star in the 1960s and 1970s
who pivoted to playing tall tough guys on
sitcoms and in movies.
Following "Police Academy," Smith reprised
his role in five sequel movies and the spinoff
TV show, co-starred on short-lived shows including
"Blue Thunder" and "Half Nelson," and turned
in appearances in "Taxi," "Hart To Hart,"
"Married… with Children," and "Coach."
In August 2011, 66-year-old Smith was found
dead at his Los Angeles home.
According to the Los Angeles Times, the L.A.
County Coroner's office conducted an autopsy
that concluded the actor died of an overdose
of weight-loss medication and also suffered
from blocked arteries, high blood pressure,
and an enlarged heart.
"Police Academy" is notable for having not
only an ensemble of likable hero characters,
but a similar ensemble of unlikable villainous
characters, including Scott Thomson's cadet
Chad Copeland.
Thomson, who before "Police Academy" also
appeared in another '80s classic, "Fast Times
at Ridgemont High," hasn't appeared in as
many "Police Academy" installments as some
of his co-stars, but he still reprised the
role in the third and fourth movies.
Thomson has continued working in film and
television since the franchise.
His TV roles include "Star Trek: The Next
Generation," "Hunter," "Parker Lewis Can't
Lose," and "True Blood," while his film roles
include "My Summer Story," "Night of the Living
Dead 3-D: Re-Animation," and "Greater."
He also matched "Police Academy" with an appearance
in one of the most popular films of the 1990s,
playing the classical music-blaring storm
chaser Preacher in "Twister."
After a couple of sitcom and soap opera gigs
in the late 1970s, Marion Ramsey finally found
a breakout role as the squeaky-voiced and
deceptively powerful cadet Laverne Hooks.
"Don't move dirtbag!"
She made her debut as Hooks in 1984's "Police
Academy" and went on to reprise the role in
five sequels, becoming a firm fan favorite.
She didn't appear in the final "Police Academy"
movie, 1994's "Mission to Moscow," because
producers couldn't find a place for her character.
This came as bad news for Ramsey, who was
going through financial troubles at the time.
She would ultimately take out a loan from
"Police Academy" co-star Bubba Smith, who
dropped out of the film over Ramsey's omission.
Ramsey would ride out the '90s and early 2000s
with small parts and voice acting work, popping
up on "Beverly Hills, 90210," "Robot Chicken,"
and the animated TV version of "The Addams
Family."
Her last role came in the musical docudrama
"When I Sing" in 2018, preceding her death
in 2021.
She was 73.
Captain Reed, the one-time boss of Cadet Mahoney's
father, sets the plot of "Police Academy"
in motion, offering Mahoney a choice of punishment
for his crimes: He can go to prison, or he
can go legit by joining the Academy.
Actor Ted Ross, best known for his Tony Award-winning
work as the Lion in the Broadway musical "The
Wiz" and its 1978 film adaptation, played
Captain Reed in the first "Police Academy,"
but he didn't return for any of the sequels.
He wrapped up a long career in show business
not long after the film's 1984 release with
appearances in "Arthur 2: On the Rocks" "The
Cosby Show," and "The Fisher King."
He retired from acting in 1991 and moved back
to his hometown of Dayton, Ohio.
In 1997, he opened a jazz club called Your
Place, where he'd perform on occasion.
After suffering a stroke in 1998 that left
him homebound, Ross died at age 68 in 2002.
Donovan Scott's screen acting career began
with a number of smaller roles in films before
he was cast as Leslie Barbara in "Police Academy."
Like Cattrall, Scott was one of the original
cast members who did not return for other
installments in the franchise.
Since "Police Academy," Scott has worked regularly
in film and television.
His film roles include "Savannah Smiles" "Splash,
Too," and "Blast from the Past," while his
TV roles include "Life with Lucy," "Alaska
Kid," "Babylon 5," "Boston Legal," "My Name
is Earl," and many others.
In recent years, Scott has taken a liking
to playing Santa Claus, and frequently appears
as Santa in various films and television series.
His many Santa appearances include episodes
of "Frasier," "It's Always Sunny in Philadelphia,"
"The Middle," "Life In Pieces," and "Superstore,"
as well as TV movies like "Northpole: Open
for Christmas" and "Santa Switch."
The character "Mr. Wig", played by Don Lake,
makes a brief but important appearance in
the first "Police Academy" movie: It's his
car that Carey Mahoney wrecks while working
as a parking lot attendant.
After "Police Academy," Lake established himself
as a recognizable character actor, becoming
a familiar face with appearances in a number
of major comedies.
Lake was a member of the troupe associated
with the mockumentaries of Christopher Guest,
and co-starred in "A Mighty Wind," "Waiting
for Guffman," "Best In Show," "For Your Consideration,"
and "Mascot" while also popping up in "Terminator
2" and "Return to Me," which he co-wrote with
frequent collaborator Bonnie Hunt.
Lake wrote for Hunt's talk show and sitcom
"Life With Bonnie," and they played the parents
of Officer Judy Hopps in Disney's "Zootopia."
More recently, Lake appeared on "Space Force"
as incompetent general Brad Gregory.
Cadet Doug Fackler is responsible for some
of the wackiest antics in the first "Police
Academy" movie.
He's played to perfection by Bruce Mahler.
"Does the radio bother you?
I can turn it down."
After his screen comedy career was launched
in earnest as a member of the cast of ABC's
late night sketch show "Fridays," Mahler played
Sgt.
Doug Fackler in four "Police Academy" movies.
He went on to play some small parts on TV
and in movies before finding his second recognizable
role: Rabbi Glickman, a friend and counselor
to Elaine Benes on "Seinfeld," with his other
notable role coming in "Friday the 13th: The
Final Chapter" He hasn't been in a feature
film since 2000, preferring instead to spend
time with his family and raise border terrier
dogs.
Portraying Cadet Kyle Blankes in "Police Academy"
was the first feature film work for actor
Brant von Hoffman, and he returned to the
franchise for 1986's "Police Academy 3: Back
in Training."
He'd dabble in film and television over the
next two decades, showing up in the films
"Rustlers' Rhapsody," "Blast from the Past,"
and "Dudley Do-Right," and on the TV series
"Home Improvement," "Arli$$," and "Arrested
Development."
He hasn't acted on screen since 2004, having
moved into a career as a writer.
With his brother, Todd von Hoffmann, the former
actor wrote two humorous pop culture compendiums:
"Big Damn Book of Sheer Manliness" and "Bigger
Damner Book of Sheer Manliness."
Chief of police in the unidentified city of
"Police Academy" and then later police commissioner,
Henry Hurst is the institutional antagonist
of the franchise, at least initially.
He's adamantly against his mayor's idea to
open up the Police Academy to a wider variety
of candidates.
He hatches the plan to make them all quit,
but after it doesn't work, comes to appreciate
the new cadets.
The acting career of George R. Robertson is
notable for two things — portraying Henry
Hurst in six "Police Academy" movies between
1984 and 1989 and for playing politicians,
both fictional and real.
Robertson was President Davis in "Senior Trip,"
Senator Barry Goldwater in "The Reagans,"
and Vice President Dick Cheney in "The Path
to 9/11."
Robertson stopped taking on as many roles
when he reached his eighties, with one of
his last roles coming in the series "Haven."
Cadet George Martin's main arc as an officer
isn't one of finding a job or personal purpose,
but one of romance: He's ditching his relentless
pursuit of as many young women as possible
in order to get together with trainer Debbie
Callahan.
Andrew Rubin was a seasoned character actor
by the time he played Cadet George Martin
in the first "Police Academy," a career peak
that followed stints on '70s TV shows like
"Mary Hartman, Mary Hartman," "S.W.A.T.,"
"The Odd Couple," "Shazam!," and "The Jeffersons."
After "Police Academy," Rubin landed main
cast parts on the short-lived drama series
"Hometown" and "Joe Bash," then walked away
from acting for about a decade to head up
multiple non-profit and humanitarian organizations.
In 2015, Rubin died of lung cancer at the
age of 69, according to The Hollywood Reporter.
The main bad guy of the original "Police Academy"
movie is never given a name.
Instead, he's a common, intimidating, leather-jacket-and-beanie-clad
street thug caricature officially listed in
the credits as "Main Bad Guy."
The part of Main Bad Guy was played by prolific
character actor and bit player Doug Lennox,
who returned to the series in "Police Academy
3: Back in Training" to portray "Axe Murderer."
He notched a few dozen credits in his time,
most notably popping up in "X-Men," "Lars
and the Real Girl," and "Against the Ropes."
He appeared in numerous television shows produced
in his native Canada, including "My Secret
Identity," "Night Heat," "Top Cops," and "Due
South."
Also a radio host and an author Lennox died
in 2015 at age 77.
Violet Fackler knows that her husband Doug
has a tendency to slip up and create mayhem.
In one memorable scene from the first "Police
Academy," she jumps on the hood of her husband's
car to prevent him from driving to the academy
sign-ups, only to get hurt in the process.
"Police Academy" is an iconic '80s movie,
and Debralee Scott was an iconic television
personality in her day: She made frequent
appearances on the celebrity-powered game
shows of the era, including "Family Feud,"
"Match Game," and "Password Plus."
As a young actor, she appeared on "The Love
Boat," had a recurring role on "Welcome Back,
Kotter," and she also played the title character's
sister, Cathy Shumway, on the soap spoof "Mary
Hartman, Mary Hartman."
Scott's career came to an end not long after
she reprised the role of Violet Fackler in
1986's "Police Academy 3: Back in Training."
She focused on her personal life and became
engaged to New York City police officer Dennis
Levi, who died at the World Trade Center during
the 9/11 terrorist attacks, according to Contact
Music.
Scott's family reported that the tragedy sent
the retired actor into a depression that led
her to drink heavily, which resulted in cirrhosis
of the liver.
Scott died in April 2005 at age 52.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
classic comedy actors are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.